ou est-ce que petit vous avez un truc où
vous étiez très bon outre nuls
j'étais très très mauvais au football à
le football mais c'est sûr parce que lui
les cages de foot u les banques à jouer
arrière fond dedans et et mon père
m'avait inscrit au puc le pari non mais
vous étiez et oui au plus que votre père
soit un grand joueur de football et en
fait j'ai été renvoyé du puck à guy
l'oni côté votre fils fait le faire
n'importe où mais pas de fédérer
pourquoi parce que vous avez des
problèmes de 2 vous êtes vous avez du
mal c'est l'ombre est maîtrisé mais il a
du mal des nations bravo il avait tout à
des problèmes de coordination voit mal
quand tu lances les entractes par là un
truc à part a lot comprend pas c'est
vrai du coup j'ai fait du tennis est
excellent il aller au pub où les jours
c'est long je suis tous les jours avait
déjà joué que moi et alors france mais
alors moi je suis bon je jouais à paris
au début joué franchement le petit jeu
coupé d'arrivée tulle avec le plus
touché devant de graves accusions la
tête de ma mère voilà qui me bats au
tennis thouars sur 2,7 ouais bah je te
le dis franchement en fait sur la vie de
ma mère
ouais voilà je vous le dis il présente
l'émission pendant un mois
[Applaudissements]
jamais il regarde toi père tu vois des
balles de ping-pong l'avancé robert toi
attendez qu est-ce qui va me dire
quelques jeux d'avant un défi qu'on
vient de me dire que tu me battais jeu
d'avants ça va être je vais pas venir
rexie les régions nouveau boeing ont
déjà une faute stupide bon tu vois des
beats électro une fois j'avais perdu sur
une grande table une fois une grande
table chez vous et vous vous avez vous
avez très bien
non je n'étais jamais venu chez moi je
veux pas de voir s'il vous plaît on
n'est pas chez votre bétail alors j'ai
tout perdu mais j'étais très doué au
piano mais vous avez tout perdu je vous
le confirme il savait 5,6 en moi et je
suis allé jusqu'à mes 16 ans et j'ai
fait le conservatoire et tout mais là je
joue plus du tout j'ai arrêté mais voilà
c'est tout et presque el hadhra fois la
jouer sur les wheat de ma mère mes
frères
c'était bien la ceni victoire est là
mais c'est pas possible et on n'est pas
sur mfm tiens oui alors oui moi je vous
ai une calculette sur votre téléphone
ouvrez là j'ai très rapide en calcul
mental je vais d'abord vérifier si vous
avez vous lui faites pas confiance a
encore fait devraient pas nous mettre le
doigt
à l'origine un truc durant vas-y alors
vas-y très rapide 2 227 +115 412 jamais
un truc bien c'est possible et ça qu'il
devait pas tarder à sa tête le verbe km
222 plus 1347 1205 1 340 alors j'ai dit
que j'étais rapide je venais que j'étais
bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
michel ragon me braun ont mis alors bon
vous aviez un con quand vous étiez jeune
tu dis pas petit ce que vous étiez
enfant ouais je sifflais ah ouais je
suis toujours dit mais quand
mais bon les années bonheur par exemple
quand le pâté à bazar qui m'a fait un
immense tube en 76 118 qui était sur le
tout leur caisse m'a demandé que je
siffle mois le tout le pont musical
vazimba siffle c'est ça ton talent
je me la circonstance bien moi je dis
chapeau
[Rires]
allez-y cyril s'est fait siffler mais
vous allez voir en fait les notes c'est
le début beaucoup alors il essaie de
nous faire trouver quelque chose
une chanson contemporaine méconnue
abonderait nous faire un truc c'est oui
quand j'étais jeune je vais faire tous
ces petits avec un si gros souffle de
gaza dyson qui m'a dit alors à vie alors
je vous faire attendre
vas-y mais c'était pas mal gré ce que tu
as fait tu me répéter on vient sur toi
non je te promets vous avez eu la fête
aux hormones live
[Musique]
c est vrai qu ils ont mis ma fille qui
chantait johnny alors oui kenny c'est
quoi votre moi j'étais très bien on
danse classique
ah ouais dans ce cas fuite
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête de ma mère c'est vous mais
regardez bah oui c'est ça le française
pendant 15 ans j'en faisais cinq heures
par semaine magnifique corps a changé
j'ai abandonné une pirouette faire un
nouveau tube ou non mais attendez non
mais si oui quelle photo mg j avais pas
du tout qu'il y avait fait de la
relativement jeune mais ou pas c'est un
petit rat de l'opéra presque j'ai passé
le concours mais je paie non c'est vrai
oui c'est un petit rat tout court d'un
moteur alors moyenne de rôle moi je sais
tout et partout tu effaces paranormaux
et pourquoi parce que c'est pas drôle
quand on compte un mort et moi c'était
j'organisais super les matchs de foot
j'organisais tout le monde des jeux
présentés tout le monde à table et la
peep hauteur en fait un jour tu pues
hypothèque watan et saison il ajouté par
l'escroc oui oui un escroc merci oui
c'était des gens discrets côté des
petits oui très jeune j'ai démarré très
tôt dans la galerie sava pas déjà que
mal fait passer pour un petter et hier
soir d'être gentil bah oui on verra les
60 hier bernard montiel bien sûr je
rappelle que rappeler paix avouée à
moitié pardonnée jalabert
grimpeuse alors ouais alors c'était très
doué pour le dessin
ouais vraiment très content qu'ils
agissent ou est en revanche je suis je
n'ai jamais su lassé des souliers jadot
un coup de gifles mon père me disait me
déposer des tennis on en refait les
aurais je n'ai jamais réussi à faire ça
et à prendre leurs semaines maintenant
quand quelqu'un me demande l'heure dans
la rue je à oui ça c'est à dessein que
j'ai fait à airtel il ya pas longtemps
au séjour a mis aussi génial atteint
c'est donc et tu arrives pas donné leur
et mène maintenant quand on me demande
l'heure j'ai trente secondes de panique
en me disant est ce que je vais savoir
donner leur déteste ça c'est ouf et fou
hein alors c'est se mettre dedans merci
et dépit mais je les arrête des six
intéresse mais c'est une très très belle
c'est magnifique ça c'est magnifique
elle a du talent
[Applaudissements]
c'est la seule map à la portée de la
vache qui vibre c'est moi qui a fait un
bon c'est pas mal mais c'est bon je me
rends je stresse à airtel je prends un
stylo et jedessine
ah ouais bah c'est génial et boîte
content de le savoir mais vous je suis
le pro de la coordination et de la
synchronisation
on veut faire un exercice hausse
ensemble non non reprenez votre doigt
droit obasi votre doigt droit le monde
voie publique alors juste pas jean louis
marc aubry
vous allez le tourner dans un sens
d'accord valeur est celle où vous prenez
l'autre doit way que vous tournez dans
l'autre sens un moyen à présent vous
tenez ça dans un sens et ça dans un
autre sens et marées même temps bah oui
bon ça va même sans ça très dur c'est le
même sens tout simplement superbes lots
dans les douces mais là tu fais moi même
faire je suis ça serait comme ça de
bonne santé eau en vrai ça donne ça donc
ses cordes et des cordes des bois de on
offert les structures et de cette
manière alors moi j'arrive pas à ses
sabots à talons
oui c'est ça qu'on veut avec vos doigts
oui c'est bon non mais attendez quoi
jean talon de mr ben ali famille mfm
tous les matins 6h 9h et tout une
nouveauté mais faible à l'adhésion
mental ou alors dû nous arrêter cela non
mais vous ne coupez pas si rude parce
que moi c'est les imitations et à chaque
fois vous êtes mal à l'aise quand je le
fais loupé et oui où
madoff voulez je peux faire un petit
medley pour fabien lecoeuvre
elle avait eu lieu voilà trois
imitations qui je suis
et attention le dernier très rapide hu
[Musique]
pour les bus soient posées aux personnes
seules pourquoi quand les gens viennent
dans cette émission ils deviennent la
meuf elle était bien l'été sur mfm mais
non elle lancé tranquillement michel
sardou est lancée tranquillement aller
tout de suite une nouveauté mais fait un
petit mari francis cabrel et depuis
qu'elle est là mon frère elle arrive
faire elle a pété un câble non mais ça
s'est passé il s'était bien non non non
mais les trois étaient hyper bien
franchement moi j'ai pas connu maroni
sardou et véronique ces derniers de la
mairie j'étais doué au football mais
j'étais cascadeur aussi ouais c'est très
doux et je faisais que des casquettes
que personne faisait au quartier
pourquoi je sautais dans l'aude à radar
berne jeu du troisième étage rien mais
quand même le sol
ah oui c'est maintenant il ya macaci
rebondissait à demain
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie que le spécialiste des
cascades raté quoi où quand il arrivait
pas sonné comme une merde